Hello, everyone in
Jonesboro and
Old Westbury.
I'm Dr. Ramos of
the Department of
Biomedical Sciences,
and I'm very
excited and honored
to be part of your
journey here at
NYTCom to graduation.
This slide basically
has the session
objectives that are
found on the CPG.
On your own, please
take a look at them
and make sure that
you're comfortable
with all the
major elements of
information that
are going to
be described in
this lecture.
So this lecture is
entitled Introduction
to the Nervous System,
but maybe a better
title would be
Introduction to the
Histology of the Nervous
System because that's
really what I'm going
to be talking about,
the different kinds
of cells in the
nervous system and how
they work together.
You have already had
a great introduction
to the nervous
system in your gross
anatomy labs and in
your OMM labs. So I
think that you all
already understand
that the nervous system
has connections to
muscles, organs,
glands, and, of course,
the nervous system
has many different
parts and is
interconnected to itself.
And it's these connections
and the activity
of cells that produces
behavior, right? So
cells in the brain
connect to muscles,
which then move the
bones in our body, right?
The nervous system
has cells in the eye,
in the ear, in
the skin to signal
environmental stimuli,
changes in light, sound,
mechanical stimulation
on our skin, right?
And so this is how
we need to understand
that the neural activity
creates behavior.
We should also
understand that changes
in the brain, right,
changes in the anatomy
and physiology of
brain cells will
cause changes in
behavior. So development,
early brain
development, is a period
where there are many
changes in anatomy and
physiology, and
this correlates with
changes in the behavior
of a growing baby,
right? There are
also changes in the
brain that take place
during normal aging.
There are changes in
the brain that take
place during the
disease process, after
injury, and after learning,
right? So learning
is a great example
where we can observe
a change in behavior
due through some
experience, right? And
that change in behavior
manifests from changes
in the connectivity
and physiology of
neural circuits, right?
And so therefore,
treatments for brain
diseases must change
the brain, right? They
must change the brain
back to a more normal
state from the
disease state or the
treatments for brain
diseases must stop whatever
pathological changes
are taking place.
And you'll learn about
neurodegeneration
and demyelination,
for example,
that are processes
that change
the anatomy of
the brain and then
lead to behavioral
deficits.
All right, let's start
with what I would
consider to be the major
players of the brain.
All cells are important,
but understanding
how the neurons are
organized, the neurons
are interconnected,
and the neurons
communicate physiologically
with one another is
so critical to
understanding brain function
and brain disease. So
the neurons are the
main information
carrying cells of the
brain. And what I
mean by that is that,
remember, the neurons,
for example, in the
periphery, connect to
muscles, right? So the
activity of the neurons
is going to cause
muscle contraction and
cause our movements,
right? Right.
Neurons in the
sensory organs,
be it the eye, the ear,
the tongue, the skin.
Right. Those cells
communicate information
about environmental
stimuli and bring those
back to the central
nervous system, carrying
information about
what is going on in
the environment and
any kind of behavioral
response that needs to
take place. So we're
going to spend most
of the time during
this block talking
mostly about the neurons.
And in this lecture,
we're going to talk
about different parts
of the neuron because
they're important to
understand how these
cells do their special
job. So neurons
are characterized by
a cell body that has
many important
intracellular organelles.
Neurons have branching
dendrites, and
we'll talk about
that. Those dendrites
often have dendritic
spines. Neurons
have an axon initial
segment that comes
out of the cell body.
They have branching
axons and axon
terminals where
neurons make contact
with other neurons.
Neurons are electrically
excitable cells
that can release and
respond to transmitters
via these connections.
And in a follow-up
lecture, we'll talk
about the physiology of
neuronal connections,
right? And something
very important is that
neurons, almost all the
neurons in the brain
are produced before
birth and almost
entirely non-renewable,
meaning if a neuron
dies, that neuron is not
replaced in whatever
circuit that neuron was
engaged in, right? So
neurodegeneration or
neuronal injury like
you might see following
a ****** is going to
result in a permanent
loss of those neurons,
right? And back in
the day, early anatomists
knew that the brain
was important for
behavior and they could
distinguish different
parts of the brain and
gray versus white
matter. But it was only
until there were the
revolution in microscopy
and cell staining
that anatomists could
look, zoom in onto a
piece of the brain here
and see that there
were many, many diverse
types of brain cells.
you can see just in
this really small section
of the neocortex of
the human brain we see
many different cells
stained here with
different shapes and sizes
and it's these big
cells here that we know
are the neurons right
so all these notice
how they these guys
have a triangular or
pyramidal shape that's
very characteristic of
the neurons in the
neocortex and then we
have some other small
cells stained here. The
big cells, we'll
learn more about this
throughout the semester,
are the neurons, and
the small cells are the
glial cells, all right?
We're going to
continue the discussion
here in the next couple
slides with neurons.
All right, so neurons
have dendrites,
right?
More sophisticated
staining techniques allowed
for visualization of
the full morphology
of neurons. And the
early anatomists noticed
how complex neurons
could be in their
morphology in different
parts of the brain. And
you have already talked
a little bit about
the dorsal root ganglion
neurons of the, of
the periphery, right?
And you might have
learned about how they
have a cell body in the
dorsal root ganglia.
They have peripheral
terminals that, let's
say, are going to the
skin, and then they
have terminals that go
to the CNS, like the
spinal cord right notice
here many different
other kinds of cells in
different parts of
the brain like the
neocortex here the
hippocampus in the olfactory
areas in the cerebellum
and in blue we're
showing the dendrites
so the dendrites are the
information receiving
part of the neuron
so when two people have
a conversation right
if we want to think of
this analogy it's that
it's the ears of both
of those people that
receive the information
from the other in
that conversation right
so they're kind of
like the the ears or
the hearing part of the
conversation between
two or more neurons
right and look how
elaborate some of the
dendrites of different
cells and different parts
of the brain can be So
this is the Purkinje
cell dendrites of cells
in the cerebellum,
right,
what I've circled there
in red. And so you'll
see how this architecture
of the dendrites
allows for many, many
thousands of neurons
to communicate with
this cell, right? So
it has many ears for all
kinds of conversations
with other cells.
So those that are a
little summary of the
dendrites of neurons
if we
zoom in even
further on to dendrites,
so here we have a
Pyramidal cell of
the neocortex and
we see all the
dendrites in green here
This this one guy
down here might be the
axon. So let's exclude
that guy but everything
else you see in green
are the dendrites.
And if we zoom in
on one segment here,
we zoom in on this
box and magnify
it, and now I
hope you can
see all these
little appendages,
little tiny
little protrusions
coming off of
the dendrite.
If you take a cross
-section through
this, you'll see these
protrusions here.
And so these are
what's called as
dendritic spines
and here this is the
Dendrite itself.
These are
dendritic spines
and these are areas
where where
neurons
preferentially make
their connections, right?
Not all neurons have
spines, but those that do
this is an area of of
exceptional connect
connectivity, synaptic
connectivity. We'll
talk about synapses
in a second. And we're
beginning to learn
a lot more about
dendritic spines, their
biology, and how they
might correlate to
disease. The whole point
of what I'll try to
show in this lecture
is how the understanding,
the histology,
understanding the
different cell
types in the brain,
you know, correlate
to our understanding
of brain
function and brain
disease, okay?
So, for example,
the children with
Fragile X syndrome,
when they've done
histology on the brain of
those children, and
remember, Fragile X
syndrome is caused by
mutations of the fmrp
gene what you observe
is that their neurons
have increased numbers
of dendritic spines
on the neocortical
dendrites right so we
now know that the fmrp
gene encodes a protein
that's important for
the homeostasis of
dendritic spines and
dendritic spines are
going to determine
the connectivity, the
conversations that
neurons can have in these
networks important for
everything that we do,
right, our behavior.
And we know that one
of the major symptoms
of Fragile X syndrome,
right, is cognitive
disability, right? And
some of that cognitive
disability manifests
from the fact that
these neurons are not
connected appropriately
because there is an
overabundance of
dendritic spines, right?
On the other hand,
when you look
at dendritic spines
in the brains
of patients with
schizophrenia,
like you see here,
the schizophrenic
dendrites have impoverished
spines compared to
a control patient,
right? And we know
schizophrenia has its own
distinct characteristic
of behavioral
change, right? And
that has to come from
somewhere. That has to
come from changes
in connectivity and
changes in physiology.
So these are two good
examples of how, you
know, of things we
already know about
dendritic spines and
what's probably yet
to come in the future.
Okay, so we've covered
a little bit about
dendrites and dendritic
spines. Now it's time
to talk about the
axons. In the analogy I
gave of two people
having a conversation, we
said it's the ears of
those two people that
are kind of like the
dendrites that can hear
the information from
the other cell, from
the other person. Well,
think of the axon as
kind of the mouth of
the neuron right that
part of two people that
expresses information
from one from one person
to the other right
and we know in our in
our picture down here
that we have our
cell body right here
we have our dendrites
shown here and then
we have an axon
right and this axon
is going to make
connections with another
neuron or make
connections to a muscle,
or to a gland, or
to the eye, right?
And this is the
information sending portion
of the cell. There is
a special part of the
axon very close to
the cell body known as
the axon initial
segment, where there are
lots of ion channels
that we'll talk about in
the next lecture we have
the main axon itself
and then at the end
we have the terminal
region right the
presynaptic terminals where
this neuron makes
contact with muscle or
another cell note in
this picture here we
have the cell body and
dendrites of a motor
neuron and notice how
that axon has branches
right it's one axon
that then branches and
makes contact with
different parts of this
muscle all right so
you see that a lot it's
not just one it's one
axon but there could
be many branches that
come that emanate from
that axon to make to
have more conversations
with more more neurons
right so axons are
found in nearly all
neurons there might
there are some neurons in
the um in the periphery
and the sensory organs
that don't have,
you know, what you
might consider to be a
classic axon, but those
are the exceptions.
Axons can vary
widely in length,
shape, and number
of branches, right?
Axon terminals,
like I said, make
contact with other
neurons and muscles,
and these are, in
summary, again,
the communicating
wires of
the neurons that
do the talking.
Something very
interesting, very important
about axons, obviously,
is that in the axonal
injury is obviously
going to really disrupt
the communication of
that network, right?
And just so like spinal
cord injury obviously
is cutting the
connections between the
brain and the spinal
cord networks that then
communicate with
muscle, for example. But
something interesting is
that peripheral nervous
system axons, right,
can often regrow when
they're severed or
injured, right? And a
process known as
Wallerian degeneration
characterizes the process
of, you know, the injured
axon dying, parts of
it dying back, and
parts that can regrow.
So let's say if you
have some kind of injury
in this neuron here,
if you have some
kind of injury here,
Valerian degeneration
causes these parts
of the axon to die
back, and you will see
new growth of the
axon to make contact
with that, to re-innervate
that target again.
So this is why axons
are so important.
um i mentioned the axon
hillock right that's
shown right here the
axon hillock and in
yellow we see staining
for sodium channels
right we'll talk about
sodium channels and
potassium channels in
the axon hillock that
are important for the
electrical activity of
the neuron and the
the generation of the
action potential, right?
And we'll talk about
in a coming slide the
cells that
produce myelin,
shown here in purple,
right? These segments of
purple that are wrapped
around by myelin.
And notice how in
between these segments
we have this little
punctate staining of
sodium channels, right
these segments in
between myelinated
portions of the axon
are called the nodes
of Ranvier right the
nodes of Ranvier are
repeating segments
of localized density
of ion channels and
other proteins used
to regenerate the
action potential right
and increase the the
speed of that
electrical signal down
the length of the axon,
especially when the
axon is very long
to reach its target.
And the node of
Ranvier, by definition,
are found in between
segments of myelin.
So there's a lot of
interesting biology
going on about
myelination and and
proteins at the nodes
of Ranvier. Something
very interesting for
you all to reflect
on is how there is
now evidence that
intellectual disability
and symptoms like
autism come from
dysfunction of the nodes
of Ranvier biology.
Okay, so CATNAP2,
C-N-T-N-A-P-2, sometimes
known as CATNAP,
encodes a gene that
is found in the
nodes of Ranvier
and important for
clustering of ion
channels at these nodes.
and mutations in
CATNAP2 gene cause
Pitt-Hopkins syndrome.
And Pitt-Hopkins
syndrome has an
interesting phenotype
of autism, speech
and language delay,
intellectual disability,
and epilepsy.
So here we have pretty
good evidence of how
important it is that
neuronal axons organize
all of the different
proteins at the
nodes of Ranvier to
allow for the right
propagation of electrical
signals down the axon.
All right and let's
zoom in now on a very
important part of
the axon known as the
axon terminal right
where you know chemical
synapses or
connections chemical
connections are made
between neurons and
muscle or neurons and
other neurons, right?
So we're zooming in
on this axon here
right at the end where
this axon terminal,
right, is making a
connection with the
postsynaptic dendrite
of another neuron. So we
call the neuron that's
doing the talking the
presynaptic neuron.
So this neuron here is
the presynaptic
neuron. And we call the
neuron that's doing
the listening here with
its dendrite as the
postsynaptic neuron,
presynaptic and postsynaptic,
right? So here we
see the presynaptic
axon terminal, and we
see these vesicles
here. These are vesicles
that have the chemical
messenger that makes
up the language of
neuronal communication.
right? And so,
again, here's our
presynaptic neuron, our
postsynaptic neuron,
and very often what
you see is that
the presynaptic
neuron's axon makes
contact with the
dendrite or the
dendritic spine of
the postsynaptic cell.
If we look at an EM
image of a presynaptic,
of a synapse, of a
chemical synapse.
Here we see the
presynaptic axon terminal
membrane. We see
some vesicles here.
Here we see the
postsynaptic dendritic or
spine membrane.
And then notice how
there's this little
space in between, right?
So that is known as
the synaptic cleft.
And then we will
talk about how
there's release of
transmitter to send
that communication
from the pre to the
postsynaptic cell.
So this is the
most common
type of synapse
that you see or
contact you see
in the brain.
Kind of the connection
from axon terminal
to another kind of
to another neuron.
And it is pretty
fast on the order of
one to five milliseconds
and throughout
this block you're
going to talk about
so many disorders
and syndromes right
and the goal here
is that when you're
learning new things
about brain disease
that you're able
to connect that to
the cell types to
their type their
parts of different
parts of the cell
how they're
interconnected and how
they they communicate
with each other
All right, here
are just a little
more pictures showing
synaptic communication
caught in the
act. So here we
have our presynaptic
axon terminal,
pre, and here we
have our postsynaptic
dendrite. Here we
have a dendritic
spine. Here's
another axon here.
I'll label that
with X for axon.
All these different
connections being received
by this dendrite
and this spine. And
notice here we have this
omega-shaped structure
here, which is a
presynaptic vesicle, right,
releasing its contents
at the synapse.
And here we have another
beautiful image again.
We have our presynaptic
vesicles here that
are fusing to exocytose
to release the
contents of that
transmitter. so really cool
and it's amazing that we
now have um microscopy
and tools to understand
more about how
neurons connect and how
they communicate all
right so there are
all kinds of different
flavors of this kind
of uh communication
these kinds of chemical
synapses where you have
axon to dendrite you
you can also have
ax so here's that
picture axon to dendrite
we have pre here on
this on the left-hand
side of this picture,
and here we have post.
Forgive the sloppy
handwriting.
And for the most part,
you'll see axon-to
-dendrite connections,
but you can also
have axon-to-cell-body
connection or axon
-to-soma, and you can
also have axon-to-axon
connections, but these
are somewhat rare
in, let's say, the
brain, a little more
common in the spinal
cord, all right? And
here another nice
lower magnification
picture of a postsynaptic
neuron labeled in
brown and we have
the presynaptic axons
targeting different
parts of the cell here
in black. So the
presynaptic axon in
black and the postsynaptic
neuron in brown.
And again And just
big picture, if we
understood all of the
kinds of connections from
all of the neurons in
the brain, then we would
solve the mystery of
how the brain works
and what goes wrong
in brain disease. And
so the major challenge
has been really
understanding and having
the map of all the kinds
of connections that
exist in the brain for
the different functions
that the brain allows
and nervous system
allows us to perform.
All right, another
kind of connection
that you see that's
different than the
one we just described,
the chemical-type
synapse, where an
axon releases a
transmitter on a
dendrite or a cell body
or an axon is a type
of connection known
as the electrical
synapse. Where's my
pointer here? The
electrical synapse.
Right?
Or also the electrical
synapse, yeah.
These, think of these
kinds of synapses like
two hands clasping
each other. but when
these two hands connect
let's say very often
you'll see electrical
synapses made by two
neurons at the at their
dendrites right these
two hands connect uh
holding on to each
other also have ion
channels that connect
the insides of the
cell to one another so
that's what you see
here if we zoom in even
further at this electrical
synapse we can see
two sets of channels
right neuron one and
neuron two both have one
set of these channels
known as gap junctions
or connections
made up of the connection
proteins right on
each side each cell
has its has its own
connection that line up,
right, that line up and
then create a pore
through which different
ions and low molecular
weight proteins can
move through, right?
And so this is a way
for one neuron to
communicate with the other
neuron, again, via
exchange of chemical
and ionic information,
right? We'll talk about
the physiology of these
kinds of synapses.
For now, what's
important is that you
appreciate the anatomy
of the histology of this
kind of synapse, known
as the electrical
synapse or the gap
junctions. You'll learn
about gap junctions in
other organ systems.
And we'll talk about
gap junctions in other
cell types in the
brain. Here we're
talking about gap
junctions connecting two
neurons to each other.
And if we take an EM
slice, if we take a
slice through here and
look at it in the
EM, here we see one
dendrite and the dendrite
of the other cell.
And we see the
electrical synapse that
they're making to one
another. There are
many different kinds
of these connexin
proteins made throughout
the body and many
different genes
encoding different types
of connexins that then
make gap junctions.
There are gap
junctions throughout
the body in many
different organ systems.
And there are about
30 diseases known
to be caused by
connexin gene mutations.
And you'll probably
cover some of those
this block, but that's
as much as I'll say
about that right now.
so we can move on and
not get too caught
up on small details.
All right, so I mentioned
how gap junctions
allow for intracellular
connections,
right? So what I'm
showing here in this
slide is an example
where this neuron here
was pierced with a
micropipette, a tiny glass
pipette containing a
dye, right? And notice
how after injecting
this one cell with the
dye, you can see many
other neurons that
also are dye labeled
within a certain radius
of this injected cell,
right? So this is
because this neuron
that was injected, right
here in the yellow arrow,
this neuron has gap
junctions or makes
electrical synapses with
all of these other
neurons in this radius,
right? So this is an
example of how something
going on in one cell,
in this case the
dye filling the neuron,
can be communicated
to the other cells via
these gap junctions.
Here's an example
of a neuron that was
injected with a dye that
makes no gap junction
or no electrical
synapses with any other
cell, right? And that's
why we only see one,
okay? This little
thing over here is
not another cell.
It's a little piece
of the axon that has
been chopped off.
So one thing that's
important also to
mention is that gap
junctions are bidirectional,
meaning that,
like you saw, the
connexin allows ion
flow from cell 1 to
cell 2, as well as
from cell 2 to cell 1,
right? In that way,
it's bidirectional.
That's a little
different than
chemical synapses,
where we really have
information moving
from the axon of
the presynaptic
cell to the dendrite
of the postsynaptic
cell, right?
And this type of
neural communication is
very, very fast, less
than one millisecond
because we're talking
about ion flow
here, so that's really
fast, much faster
than release of
transmitter, transmitter
binding to the receptor
on the postsynaptic
neuron. That takes
more time, even
though that's still,
you know, fast on the
order of one, two,
three milliseconds.
All right, and the
last part of the
neuron, so this part
of the lecture has
been all about neurons
and the different
anatomy of neurons,
right? Dendrite,
axon, axon
-hillock, terminal.
We're kind of skipping
over cell body
because I know you've
covered a lot of
that in some of the early
parts of foundations
when you're just
talking about
basic, you know,
biochemistry or genetics.
and another important
part of the neuron
where there is
growing research and
growing information
coming out and information
that relates to
disease is the neuronal
cilia or psyllium
right So neurons
have a psyllium,
just like many other
cells in the body that
you'll learn about.
Neurons have one
psyllium that
generally comes out
from between the
cell body and the
dendrite. So here
you can see this
is the cell body.
And here we have the main
trunk of the dendrite.
and notice in red
here is the cilium of
this neuron here's the
cilium of this neuron
over here and i like
this cartoon that
shows kind of the
general morphology of the
neuron so we have
the cell body we have
the nucleus here ad stands
for apical dendrites
so this will just
continue and you know
remember our branching
dendrites and then
down here we have
the axon right and
notice in red we have
the psyllium if you if
you take em prepare
em material of the
brain you'll see the
psyllium here of neurons
and the reason this
is so important is
because there is a
growing number of diseases
where mutation of genes
that are important
for cilia development
cause different
clinical manifestations
depending on the
organ, okay? And one of
those genes affecting
brain function is
ALR13B. ALR13B causes
deficits in cilia
development in neurons.
where is my cilia
development in neurons
and manifests in a
syndrome called Joubert
syndrome, right,
that's characterized by
malformations of
midbrain and hindbrain
regions, causes
intellectual disability,
retinal dystrophy,
renal disease, and
other issues in
the periphery,
okay? So I hope this
is convincing
information that all
parts of the neuron
are important.
And we're learning
more and more
about how different
parts of the neuron
and dysfunction
of those parts or
genetic mutation
that then affects
development translates
into disease.
all right so that
pretty much wraps up our
discussion of neurons
and their morphology
and I want to make sure
that you guys think
about how all of these
different parts of
the neuron can play
different roles in how
the brain works normally
and where things can
go wrong in disease
um you'll learn in
upcoming lectures how
about different parts
of the brain and the
neurons that are located
in that particular
part you'll see that
there's so much diversity
in terms of neuron
biology throughout
the brain neurons can
vary in their
morphology right their
shape their dendritic
and axonal features,
whether they have
spines in the dendrites
or not. Obviously,
they're going to
vary in their
connectivity, right? Are
they motor or sensory?
Are they involved
in one particular
network for emotion or
cognition or, you
know, sleep-wake or
hunger, any of those
things? You'll learn
in upcoming lectures
about the neurotransmitter
profile, and
we'll talk in an
upcoming lectures about
neurons that release
glutamate and GABA
and acetylcholine.
There are many other
molecular markers
that distinguish
different neuron types,
and these molecules
play a role in how
these neurons carry
out their function.
And, of course,
different neurons exist
in different networks,
like I mentioned,
in the motor systems
or in the cerebellum,
in the amygdala, et
cetera. So a lot of
exciting things to come.
And in the
background, of course,
is this picture
that you have
in your mind
about, you know,
dendrites, axons,
terminals, ion channels,
and how all these
things come together.
all right so we're
going to switch gears
now and talk about
the other major cell
population in the
nervous system called the
glial cells the glial
cells are not neurons
they're they're called
glia and they're
you know supporting
cells and but they still
play a very you know
huge huge role in
brain health and brain
disease um what's
different about glia
is that we don't have
glia don't connect
to muscle right to to
contract the muscle
so in that sense they
they're not carrying
that kind of information
important for movement
right glia don't
connect um the glia
don't play the same role
in processing you know
photons of light in
the retina to tell us
about the visual world
right or glia don't
play the same role
in our skin to tell
us about uh mechanical
or chemical stimulation
of the skin, like a
bee stinging you, right,
or a mosquito biting
you. That's carried
by neurons. So that's
where, you know,
glial cells play a
different but still
very important role. The
major types of glia in
the nervous system are
the astrocytes, the
myelin producing cells,
the oligos and the
Schwann cells, and
then the microglia,
okay? Now astrocytes,
oligos and microglia
are connected to each
other in interesting ways
that we're just going
to scratch the surface
on in this course.
But they are interconnected,
and there are
some rules of
connectivity between them.
All right, let's start
with the astrocytes.
They are the
structural partners at
chemical synapse
capable of glutamate and
potassium ion uptake.
So what does that
mean? Take a look at
this neuron in black,
right, that is
receiving input on its
dendrites. Let's zoom
in here at a synapse.
So here's the dendrite
and the dendritic
spine of the neuron
in black, which is a
post-synaptic neuron.
And then here in
the, I guess, greenish
color is an axon,
right? An axon making
a chemical synapse
right here. And in
white, you can see the
neurotransmitter
filled vesicles, right?
And what's important
is look at how
the astrocyte, the
pink astrocyte here,
look how it has a
process, process meaning
like, we don't say,
We don't use the
term dendrite for
astrocyte, you know,
extensions. We use
the term process. The
astrocyte process wraps
around the synapse,
right? And then, therefore,
making it, putting
it in a perfect position
to suck up extra
neurotransmitter that
might be released by the
presynaptic neuron,
right? Or regulating
ions, ion balance in
the extracellular space.
right look how this
astrocyte also makes
contact with this blood
vessel here and this
blood vessel here
right and if we zoom in
further you can see um
that in pink how this
axon has processes or
what they call as the
end feet that make can
make contact with the
with the um with the
vasculature So here
in black, we see some
astrocytes, and in brown,
we have a blood
vessel, and you can see
right here, if we zoom
in on this in box B,
you can see how this
astrocyte process
has end feet that
contact the blood
vessel. Here's another
example here, right?
So in this way,
astrocytes can detect
what's going on in
the vasculature.
let me show you this
neat movie of an
astrocyte that's
receiving information from
the blood vessel when
the vessel dilates,
right? So our astrocyte
is in green, and
whenever intracellular
calcium changes
in that astrocyte,
which means the neuron
is, excuse me, the
astrocyte is working,
is processing information,
you'll see the
intensity of the
green signal increase.
So, let me, that
was a little fast.
Let me go back.
Notice how here,
right around
here, is the blood
vessel is increasing
in diameter.
And now look at the
astrocyte end foot,
processing that
information,
right? And now this
astrocyte, we said,
you know, is now
receiving information
and it can communicate
this information
about changes in
the hemodynamics.
And how can the astrocyte
communicate? Well,
via gap junctions.
So here we have an
astrocyte that's being
filled with a micropipette
and a fluorescent dye,
and look at all the
different astrocytes
surrounding that one
astrocyte that are also
filled with the dye,
right? So when this
astrocyte is active,
responding to something
in the environment
or blood vessel
hemodynamics, it
can communicate that
to other astrocytes,
right? And we're
still, you know,
learning, there's much
more to learn about
how astrocytes
communicate information
in the healthy and
in diseased brain.
Astrocytes also respond
to injury by trying to,
you know, make a scar
or reorganize the
structural integrity of
the tissue in response
to, let's say,
mechanical injury, right?
or a hypoxic event
that ends up killing
a lot of neurons,
right? And so this is
the kind of astrocyte
histology you'll see
in the healthy brain.
And then notice how,
in response to injury,
you get a change in
the morphology of the
astrocyte. And here
we're seeing the
formation of a glial scar
due to some kind of
penetrating injury.
Look at how much
darker the staining
is. And the staining
here is for GFAP,
which stands for glial
fibrillary
acidic protein,
right? This is a
marker, is a molecular
marker and gold standard
for reactive astrocytes.
Reactive astrocytes,
meaning astrocytes
that are now undergoing
a job of trying
to respond to injury
to help the brain
recover, right? and
reactive astrocytes and
GFAP is a marker for
reactive astrocytes
and gliosis that you
will see in brain injury
and other types of
brain diseases and
GFAP is a marker used
to identify tumors made
up of astrocytes
known as astrocytomas.
We talked a little bit
about how all these
different glia kind of
communicate with one
another and can
interconnect well mutations
in gfap cause a disease
known as alexander
disease leukodystrophy
right which is
characterized by changes
in white matter right
or axon my myelination
important for axon
function okay and
these affected children
have white matter
disruption, white matter
deficits, and they have
cognitive and motor
delays and loss of
motor control. So we
see how important
astrocytes are in many
different aspects of
brain health and disease.
Microglia, let's move
from astrocytes to
microglia. These are
the immune cells of the
nervous system. They're
capable of phagocytosis
of cell debris or a
microbial invader right
they can release
cytokines and also trigger
inflammation right
they change shape in
response to injury
infection or inflammation
so this is what a healthy
microglia will look
like but at what it
will transition to this
these different shapes
and when it and and
this kind of shape here
is very characteristic
of uh peripheral or
peripheral macrophages
and this is the kind
of shape that you'll
see when a microglia
is going to phagocytose
cell debris or a
microbe. Check out
this video of
microglia labeled in
green responding
to chemical injury
here in this micro
pipette, right?
So you can see the
processes of the
microglia coming to
investigate what's
going on, what's
happening there.
It's amazing, right?
So these are the
microglia are the
kind of immune cells
of the nervous system.
Check out this
video of a dying
neuron in red. So we
can watch the video
of the neuron
dying here in red,
right? You see its cell
body basically
disappearing.
But when we also image
the microglia at the
same time you can see
in green the microglia
in green you can see
that the microglia
identifies the
dying neuron
and comes and
swallows it up right
hopefully can
you see how now
the microglia has
the red cell body
inside of it, right?
And so this is
how microglia do
their job, okay?
I have one more
video of the brain
being injured here,
but with a laser,
right? and you'll
start and you'll see a
microglial cell coming
to investigate what's
going on is there a
foreign invader do we need
to phagocytose something
so it's incredible
and we're learning more
about how microglia
play a role in disease
and brain health.
Let's move from
microglia to the myelin
-producing cells
of the brain, of
the nervous system,
which are the
oligodendrocytes and
the Schwann cells.
So the oligos
produce myelin in the
central nervous
system, whereas the
Schwann cells produce
myelin for the
peripheral nervous
system, right? Oligos
can envelop more
than one axon, but
Schwann cells envelop
only one axon.
And both cell types
obviously play a role
in diseases where you
have demyelination
or dysmyelination,
right? Like multiple
sclerosis. And what's
interesting about
oligodendrocytes is that
they're continuously
produced in the brain
as are astrocytes
and microglia, if I
didn't mention that.
Astrocytes, microglia,
and oligos are
continuously produced
in the brain and in
the nervous system.
And that's how you can
have diseases where
you have, you know,
demyelination and
remyelination, you know,
as characteristic of
that of that disease
phenotype and so what
we see here is in this
in this image here we
have the dark staining
which is for myelin
or you can see how
much myelin is in is in
the brain and in this
cartoon here of the
spinal cord we have a
motor neuron whose axon
is being myelinated
by an oligodendrocyte
while it's still in
the cord and then as
the axon exits the cord
now in the periphery
part of that axon is
now myelinated by the
Schwann cells right
so obviously we
talked about the four
myelin and the nodes
in between segments of
myelin known as the
nodes of Ranvier
right and we're learning
There's so much to
learn about oligos
and Schwann cells as
it relates to disease
and demyelination.
And something interesting
that is emerging
is the autoimmune
disorders where
patients develop
autoantibodies against
myelin proteins,
right? Like MOG is
myelin oligodendrocyte
glycoprotein. And
patients with
antibodies against this
protein are going to
have demyelination.
And that disorder is
known as MOGAD or MOG
antibody disorder. And
you have inflammation,
you have
demyelination, you have
optic neuritis,
transverse myelitis, and
other problems in
the periphery, right?
Because axons and the
myelin found on those
axons are so important
in so many different
aspects of our health
and our behavior.
And Olig2 is a marker
for oligodendrocytes.
And there is a
type of neoplasm
known as
oligodendroglioma, right?
And Olig2 is a marker
for that kind of tumor.
And people with that
tumor, depending on
where it is, can
present with all kinds
of different symptoms,
headache, weakness,
seizures, et cetera.
So I mentioned this
again as understanding
the histology of
the brain, understanding
markers that
distinguish one cell
type from the other,
understanding different
parts of all the cells
in the nervous system,
help us understand
the healthy brain
and diseased brain.
All right, so
there are plenty of
other non-neuronal
and non-glial cells
in the nervous
system, particularly
as they relate to
the vasculature.
Obviously, you have
endothelial cells
that make up the blood
vessels. You have
smooth muscle cells.
They're important
in vasomotion,
vasodilation,
vasoconstriction. And
there are also interesting
cells known as
pericytes that are
also in contact with
the vasculature,
right? And all these
cells can communicate
with other glial
cell types as well.
So this is an
amazing picture of
pericytes and of cells
associated with the
vasculature,
right? Here you see
they're slightly
different depending on
if you're in a venule
or an arterial,
right? The smooth
muscle cells of the
arterial have our
kind of wrap around
like a band, right?
And obviously we know
the arteries are
capable of vasomotion,
right? And the
venules not really.
So we see how these
cells can produce that
vascular physiology.
and I have a neat
little video here of a
smooth muscle cell as
it participates in
vasoconstriction, right?
So the vessel dilates
in red is the vessel
and in green we have
the smooth muscle
cell and you can see
changes in fluorescence
over here in
the green alone
that correspond to
changes in the
vasomotion,
right? So many
different aspects of
brain function need
to be considered,
right, when trying
to understand how the
brain works and how
it affects disease.
All right. And there
are even another set of
cells in the nervous
system that need to
be discussed. These
are associated with
barriers, such as the
barrier cells that line the
ventricles, or the
cells that are present
inside the ventricles
that help produce
cerebral spinal fluid.
And all these cells will
be discussed in an
upcoming lecture on the
blood-brain barrier and
the meninges, right,
which are the
covering layers that's
surrounding the brain
in between the nervous
system and, let's say,
the skull, for example.
All right.
So let's put it kind
of all together that,
you know, in the
background, we obviously
understand the brain
controls behavior via
the activity of
interconnected brain cells.
And I'm going to change
this next year to
say the nervous system
controls behavior,
not just brain, but
we need to consider
central and peripheral,
right? There exist
diverse cell types in
the nervous system and
neurons, glia, et
cetera, with different
functions, different
morphologies, et cetera.
And understanding
these will help us
understand the healthy
and diseased brain.
Please give me some
feedback on this lecture.
When you get a
chance, click on that
link, and I welcome
all the feedback.
Please reach out to
me with any questions
that you might have,
and I look forward
to the next lecture
where we meet again.